thanks for pointing this out so yeah
this is the second talk in our to talk
series on fine-grained counting
complexity last time we are told you
about exponential time counting and
where today I'm going to talk about
parameterize aspects of counting
problems and yeah let's see what that
means so to begin with last time hager
started by introducing classical
counting problems to you so in classical
counting we have a generic counting
problem sharpie where you're given some
object X and you interested as output in
the number of some structures appearing
in X or being related to X so one first
example could be gone three set where
you're given three CNF formula fight and
you're interested in the number of
satisfying assignment to this formula
another problem would be counting sub
graphs so here you're given as input a
pattern graph H and a host graph G and
the quantity you are interested in is
the number of H copies in G so we will
discuss this in more detail later and
one very specific instance of the sub
graph counting problem would be that of
counting perfect matchings or
equivalently in bipartite graphs the
permanent here you're given as input a
graph and you just want to up with the
number of perfect matchings in G so in
classical counting complexity and the
outcomes you can typically expect our
that your problems polynomial-time
solvable or sharpy heart and the twin
reductions and just as the recap Sharpie
hardness and the touring reductions and
in the case of counting problems means
that we have a poly time algorithm that
sauce country said when given an Oracle
for the counting problem sharpie and of
course under this notion we have just
really shown that counting three set is
Sharpie heart also counting subgraphs a
Sharpie heart because this assumes as a
special case the problem of counting
clicks and in fact there is a reduction
from feast upon three set to deciding
whether graph contains to the click of a
given size and this reduction preserves
the number of solutions so we end up
with a with hardness or this problem as
well but more interestingly there is
also hardened without accounting perfect
now
shrinks by Valiants famous result for
the permanent so this is of course
interesting because here you really need
these touring reductions and in
particular you cannot use reductions
that preserve the number of solutions
because yeah if you had that and you had
a poly time algorithm for country set so
it turns out that here we have three
sharp we had problems then from that
sample I want to conclude that most
problems are Sharpie heart and I think
our guy did something similar last time
so there are ways of relaxing this this
hard notion to obtain some kind of
tractability and hug represented to your
approximation and sub exponential
counting in this talk I focus on
parameterize counting as some way of
relaxing hard problems so in
parameterize counting the the objection
study are again counting problems where
you have an input in your asked for the
number of some structures appearing that
input but you additionally of this
parameter kappa which maps instances to
natural numbers and it in some way
measures the d hardness of your instance
and then examples where such
parameterize counting problems could be
you're given a graph and the number k
and you're interested in the number of
caber Tex covers in G so this is just
the counting version of count of vertex
covers and you can be given a graph G
and you parameterize by the maximum
degree of that graph and you want to
output the number of perfect matchings
so this would be a perimeter ization of
counting perfect matchings and then we
have to sub graph counting problems in
this left one you want to count the
number of cake leaks in a graph in the
right one you want to count cage cycles
in a graph and in both cases the
parameter that we impose on this problem
is K so yeah we can see that by simply
brute force all of these problems except
the middle one can be solved in time n
to the K plus some constant so it kind
of makes sense to study these from a
primary test point of view and that the
middle one doesn't have this property
because in fact it's already Sharpie
hard for maximum degree three so there
is a sharpie harkins desire for counting
perfect
matchings and graphs of maximum degree 3
so we are not going to include problems
like this one which are already hard for
a fixed parameter in our studies and for
the other problems so the yellow ones of
course the next step is to ask whether
they're fpt so just as a reminder in the
problem is fpt and this applies also to
counting problems if we can solve it in
time f of parameter x some polynomial in
the input size who are some computable
function f and yeah it can actually be
observed and this was done by human goya
that's this classical branching
algorithm for deciding whether graph has
a k vertex cover and can be adapted to
one that also counts that K vertex
covers in a graph so this problem would
be fpt but other problems like counting
k clicks on a graph or counting case
like a sonographer are not fpt or at
least not known to be fpt and in the
case of counting k cycles sorry in the
case of counting k clicks this is
probably not too surprising because we
already know that deciding whether graph
contains a cake league is w1 heart so we
don't expect to get an FPT algorithm for
the more more general problem of
counting these clicks but for the case
of counting case like this the the
situation is different so there we have
an FPT algorithm for decision and we
still don't have an FPT algorithm for
counting so this is somehow this is
somehow an analog on of let's say
counting perfect matchings in in the
classical sense you have a problem where
the decision version seems to be whether
this decision version is actually fpt
but the counting version seems to be
harder but we cannot answer what's going
on with classical parameterize
complexity here so what we need is this
notion of parameters counting complexity
which was introduced by flamingo so in
parameterize counting complexity we're
looking at problem Sharpie like this one
and they can be fpt or they can be sharp
w1 hard or we don't know but let's just
rule out this case for now so a problem
is sharp w1 heart in this setting if
there is a reduction from county and
cake leagues to that problem and this
has to be a prime
price reduction so let me just sketch
what that means and that's an FPT
algorithm that allows you to count k
clicks if you're given a sharpie Oracle
with the additional property that for
every query that there is asked that its
algorithm the parameter on why is
bounded by some computable function okay
okay so this is the the framework of
parameterize counting complexity and if
we apply this to the problems that i
mentioned before then we have just shown
that counting cake leads to chartres be
one heart by definition but more
interestingly it was shown by human gua
that yeah the problem of counting case
cycles is actually also sharp w1 heart
so this gives us a justification for
believing that counting case like we
should not have an FPT algorithm okay so
this would be the general framework that
that we interested in and we will be
looking at problems and study whether
they're fpt or shrub w1 heart and the
remainder of the stock in particular we
look at the following two problems so in
this talk I'll focus on on two problems
in the first one we just have this sub
graph as a morphism counting problem so
you're given as input a pattern graph H
and the host graph G and the parameter
would be the size of the pattern graph
so it's number of vertices and the
output is the number of H copies in G
and in this right problem we will be
studying with a special case of the sub
graph isomorphism problem what we don't
we don't parameterize by the size of the
of the sub graph that we want to count
but rather by structural parameters on G
so on the Left problem we have a
parameter on H in the right problem we
have 10 G and we want to count the
number of perfect matchings appearing in
G so again in this left problem small
parameter means that we have a small
solution size in the right problem a
small parameter means that the graph is
somehow simple and the nice thing is
that these two problems are related so
you can reduce from one to another and
actually you can get fine-grained
results from wine direct from one
direction to the other
okay and yeah let me start the the first
part of this talk where I'll be studying
this counting subgraphs problem so just
as a reminder and to have that on a
slide and the problem we are considering
is we're given a pattern graph H which
has K vertices we are given a host graph
G on the right hand side which has n
vertices and our task is to count those
sub graphs of G which are isomorphic to
H and sub graph in that setting means
that it does not have to be it's not
necessarily induced so there is a
trivial brute force I wouldn't allows
you to solve this problem time F of K
times n to the K plus some constant you
can just by brute force guess k vertices
in the host graph and then this induce
some sub graph and in this and usurpers
you just count the edge copies appearing
that sub graph in time F of K but there
are graph classes in which we can get
non-trivial improvements so one example
would be in the class of clicks so you
can count so you can decide whether
graph contains ok click in time and to
the Omega K third and actually this
algorithm also extends to counting here
Omega is the exponent of matrix
multiplication and this essentially
exploits that you can count triangles
and time n to the Omega by computing the
trace of sub matrix product and then you
essentially reduce counting clicks of
size K third and so you would use
counting clicks of size K to counting
clicks of size K third and ya composed
this with a with some triangle
construction which gives you this
runnington i guess it was seen that
actually so another another problem
where you can get non-trivial
improvements is that of counting k
cycles so it was shown by be reckoned
and others that you can count k cycles
in time and to the 0.46 times K and this
is somewhat interesting because I mean
first of all it improves upon this
trivial n to the K thing but it actually
improves upon something that was known
the meeting
middle barrier so for some time it was
believed that kind of the optimal
running time for problems like counting
case like this might be n to the K
halves and as you can see this is lower
so this is quite a quite a non-trivial
thing to say and yes all of these these
algorithms so far should have running
times which are of the form n to the K
and are there also problems where you
can get fpt time or maybe even poorly
time so yes there are examples where
that as well that they usually look
pretty simple so so one example for a
pattern graph that you can actually
count in polynomial time would be the
case star so in a case star you just
have one one Center vertex which is
violet and there are K race around that
and you can count that in linear time
because the number of K stars in the
graph is just this expression here so
you sum over all vertices appearing in
your graph this binomial coefficient
which is the degree of the vertex over K
because once you guessed a vertex that
your Center can map into you just have
this binomial coefficient many choices
for mapping the race into the
neighborhood of that vertex ok and yeah
so we've seen that there they are graph
classes in which you can get non-trivial
improvement sometimes even ranging into
into the realm of polynomial time
feasibility so it is very natural to ask
now what happens for general classes so
let's say we fix some graph Class C and
henceforth we will restrict our pattern
to be drawn from that pattern Class C so
for which classes can we get FP t time
rather than some n to the K time this
way this would be a problem that we be
focusing on in the remainder of this
part so
yeah let me just rephrase this so let's
say we're given a graph class c which is
recursively enumerable then we define a
problem Khan Saab restricted to see so
you're given a simple a pattern graph
from C and a general graph G you
parameterize by the solution size so by
the size by the number of vertices in H
and you're interested in the number of H
copies appearing in G so this is a class
of problems one problem for each graph
class and then what you could show is
that there is a dichotomy for this
problem for this set of problems along
the maximum matching size in the Class C
so there's a positive case so if your
graph Class C contains only constantly
large matchings so the maximum matching
number in this graph Class C is bounded
by some constant then you actually get a
poly time algorithm so not even fpt but
just even poli time and well examples
for graph classes that have maximum
matching spotted by a constant would be
the stars as we've seen before almost
all graphs that have some vertex cover
of a bounded size and on the other side
of the dichotomy the hard cases are
given by those graph classes which are
unbounded so whenever you have a graph
Class C which has unbounded matchings
and the matchings don't have to appear
is induced subgraphs is just ok that you
have sub graphs which are matching and
then you can show chart w1 hardness of
this problem so this includes them the
Pops the cycles which have large
matchings of course and I mean it also
includes the class of matchings because
matchings typically tend to have
unbounded matchings and yeah what is
somewhat interesting is that this
dichotomy and which I've sketched here
actually classifies exactly when the
problem of counting sup girls from a
fixed classes polynomial-time solvable
if you're willing to assume that FP t is
not equal to share w one so you you take
an assumption from parameterize
complexity and you end up with the
classification for polynomial time
solubility
so when even if you're not interested in
fpt at all then this could be a reason
for studying it because you actually get
results and classical complexity from it
and in fact you can show that in a way
an assumption stronger than P naught
equal to sharpie FP naughty puta sharpie
and it's necessary to prove such a
dichotomy okay and yeah so counting
suppress is hard once these have
unbounded matchings what I want to show
in the following is a hardness proof for
one specific graph class so the minimal
graph class to which you can get sharp
w1 hardness which would according to
this dichotomy just be the class of
matchings so in the remainder of this
talk I focus on and counting game
etchings and I want to show the
described in chapter but one heart here
you can see a problem here you can see a
person was trying to count three
matchings in a graph and she collapsed
over the task so this picture should
somehow visually convey to you that
counting he mentions the sharp w1 heart
it took it myself it's hard to get this
as a stock photo and so I would also
like to give you less pictorial argument
why counter k matching the chapter one
hurts a more formal one so I want to
show that there is an FPT reduction from
counting k clicks to counting k
matchings so it's an FPT algorithm that
allows you to count k clicks if you're
given an oracle for counting matchings
of some size function of k and then yeah
this problem or this leg proofs for this
problem have some kind of infamous
history and there was a first attempt
where where the reduction was over some
problem called accounting cycle covers
and it ended up in in a weighted version
of this problem so we couldn't show full
hardness then later we could reduce from
this counting cyclic covers to actually
unweighted matchings
but last year Daniel and I have managed
to to get a yeah significantly easier
and somehow less OPAC proof for for this
hardness result so in this in this new
route which is this bottom rail shown
here we first use counting clicks to
counting colorful sub graphs of Maxim
degree three and then from this problem
we go to a colored version of this
matter of the counting matching problems
and in the end we get rid of colors by
some simple inclusion exclusion argument
so the the color of an arrow in this
picture should just indicate the like
the complexity of the proof involved for
proving that reduction so so last year
we had a way to proof that used to green
arrows and one yellow arrow and a few
weeks known actually not a few weeks ago
but a few months ago by now and we we
found actually a a new proof for this
yellow arrow so by now there is a route
there is a path from clicks to matchings
which uses only green arrows and this is
what I want to sketch now so this is the
path we consider we know what was done
before and we first use counting clicks
to counting colorful sub graphs of
maximum degree three so let me define
this problem and in in the colored
subgraphs problem you are given two
graphs H&G so H is again a pattern and
GS GS some host graph and in addition
you also have colorings on these graphs
so these are just assignments of colors
from one up to ke to the vertices of H
and G and what you're interested in is
the number of color preserving H copies
in G which will be denote by this sharp
sub of HMG so color preserving H copy is
just a it's a subgraph of g which is
isomorphic to h respecting colors so the
isomorphism is supposed to map vertices
of a given color two vertices of the
same color and then particularly we will
focus on on this problem in the setting
that H has a bioactive coloring so in
that case we speak of a color for
sub graph and the maximum degree of H is
also supposed supposedly bounded by
three so even in that specific in this
special case we can show that a problem
a sharp w1 hard by very simple reduction
from clicks to multicolored clicks and
then ending up in this problem and in
fact by by this can you beat rebirth
result by Daniel and we can also show
that this problem has an end to the
Omega K over log K time lower bound
undercounting ETH so we have this the
source problem of counting colorful sub
graphs and we now want to reduce this to
counting colored matchings so to do this
we use a technique that we call vertex
explosions and it yeah so this name
actually kind of makes sense and so in a
vertex explosion I'd say we have the
setting with the setting that we want to
count them copies of some colorful graph
H in a colored graph G so we interested
in this quantity of these copies and
what we do now is we take this graph H
and we explode this yellow vertex so an
explosion just means that you so this
vertex V which is this yellow vertex
here and will be deleted and the two
edges which are which were incident with
that vertex will just get a vertex of
the yellow color this gives you this
graph here where we reduce this one
degree to vertex two two vertices which
each have to agree one and the great
thing about explosions is that if you
can count explosions so if you can count
this exploded graph H Prime in like say
two graphs that we construct from G then
you can from that we cover the number of
sub graphs which are isomorphic to H in
the original graph G so you end up with
using the instance h2g so this instance
of counting H&G can be reduced to two
instances of counting H Prime and some
graph g one and then another graph g
prime so once you know these two numbers
you can compute
from this person very simple linear
algebra its original number of sub
graphs okay and let me just show how to
do this so let's say we have this
exploded graph then the new instances
that we construct these graphs GI so the
graph is the graph G is just defined by
taking for each yellow vertex and in the
original graph a copy of that graph of
that vertex which is just a vertex on
the same neighborhood which will not be
adjacent to to the original vertex so
each original vertex in G will be
replaced by a block and independent set
of I vertices which all have the same
neighborhood as the previous vertex and
and then we can see that the number of
or actually the H copies in the graph G
I they they can be partitioned into two
types so in the first type these two
yellow vertices which arise from the
explosion are contained in the same
block and in the second case they are
contained in different blocks so we can
then see that actually this first case
by contracting these two vertices to one
we end up with a copy of H and G whereas
in the second case you get a copy of H
Prime in G and ok so this is not
entirely true and actually this true but
but to get from these graphs to this
number of sub graphs we have to multiply
by some constants because a given sub
graph H and G can be extended in
different ways to some sub graph copy of
h prime of G I and this will give some
coefficients and yeah we can actually
check that the number of H prime sub
graphs in g1 this is just by definition
the number of H prime sub graphs and G
because GI was a g1 is obtained from g
by adding nothing so this equation is
just is just trivia in the second in the
second case we want to count the copies
of H Prime in Simon graph G 2 in this
graph G 2 and then we can actually see
that so the number of H prime copies in
g2 corresponds to
twice the number of H copies mg because
an H copy of g is one that hits where
the two vertices hit the same block and
there are two ways of doing this so you
can either take this assignment or the
one where these two are flipped and a
subgraph copy of h prime in g can be
extended in four different ways to a
copy of h prime in g2 because here in
this sub graph copy you will have two
two blocks which are hit and in each of
these blocks you have two independent
choices so you end up with four so in
other words you you just got the linear
system that gives you so these are the
known values which are copies of H Prime
in some other graph in some other graph
where H prime is this graph that you get
by exploding h and here you have some
quantities of which this one is the one
you are interested in so this is the
number of H copies in G where H was this
an unexploded graph so if you can count
explosions then you can solve this
linear system of equations which
obviously has full rank so you end up
recovering this value that you were
interested in the first place and
actually the same approach also allows
you to to explore the vertex of degree 3
so there you just end up ok here we
explode the screen vertex and end up
with three vertices of degree 1 and we
have to construct three instances g1 g2
and g3 and yeah all together we've seen
that we can now explore vertices of
degree 2 we can explore vertices of
degree 3 and the idea is now to to
construct a chain of explosions where we
successively explode the vertices of our
color photograph until we end up with a
matching and each step is just solving
some linear equation system which has
two or three equations and has full rank
so this is very simple ok and let me
just State this a bit more explicitly so
so this chain of explosions looks as
follows we start with this instance of
counting a colored a colorful sub graph
H and G and this colorful sub graph has
k vertices and edges and its maximum
degree is bound by three so then we
let's say we explode the CLO vertex and
we end up with the vertex that has with
a graph that has one less vertex of
degree not equal to 1 and n 2 instances
for for the sub graph counting problem
so these are the two instances g1 and g2
that we constructed before so we can if
we can solve each of these two instances
then we end up with the solution for
this and then once we exploded this we
can now explore the next vertex we again
we moved one vertex of degree not equal
to one and so to solve this instance of
counting H Prime in GI and g1 we we get
three instances of counting H prime
prime and g 11 g 12 and g3 and likewise
you can also get in three instance for
g2 and then then you see of course that
if you repeat this explosion chain for
4k steps then you end up with the
colored matching with a colored matching
on L edges so this would be this graph
after doing k explosions where where
each edge that was previously present in
your breath it's not just a a singleton
edge as in it's ok to on some colors so
you know want to count this HK in some 3
to the K number of grafts and if you can
solve all of these instances of counting
colored matchings then you can solve
your original sharp w1 heart problem so
this gives a reduction from counting
colorful subgraphs to counting colored k
metrics ok let me recap so there is a
reduction from counting clicks to
accounting colorful sub graphs which was
this problem doing this chain of
explosions gives you a colored matching
and in the end where you can get rid of
these colors by some simple inclusion
exclusion argument which I don't have
time to sketch in orbit but it's easy to
check essentially use hear that that
each edge has a unique pair of colors
appearing in it so you can in particular
account those those matchings in an
uncle
graph which would avoid a certain set of
edge colors and this is a setting where
you can apply inclusion exclusion and
then also quite nicely is that since
there's this lower bound for counting
colorful sub graphs we also get lower
bounds for counting matchings under
Sharpie th and these lower bounds aren't
working not really tight but I mentioned
later what what could be possibly done
to to get titled or bones here okay then
let me just summarize this first half of
the talk so in this first half we were
considering this sub graph counting
problem where you're given a pattern and
the host in your parameters by the size
of the pattern and we've seen that this
problem is trap w one heart if the
pattern is a matching and more generally
I mentioned that there is a hardness
proof that shows that the problem
chapter one hard whenever H contains a
large matching and then using a lower
bound for accounting colorful edge
subgraphs accounting colorful allege sub
graphs we get a we get an almost I'd
lower bound for this problem and it
sharpie THS way okay this concludes the
first half of my talk I have to switch
the presentations now because apparently
PowerPoint uses some exponential time
algorithms to to render the slide then
it's better to have two instances of
size and house rather than one instance
of size n and so this is the second part
of this talk where we will consider
counting perfect matchings by structural
parameters and then yeah let me just
recap from from last time what we know
about this problem so it was shown by
valiant that that counting perfect
matchings a sharp Sharpie heart even on
bipartite graphs and I mentioned before
that this holds even if the degree the
maximum degree of your graph is bonded
by three so in other words yeah I'm
counting perfect matchings parameters by
the degree is so if you want to prime
trust by the degree then you don't have
end up with a structural parameter that
is interesting from this problem and to
actually show parameters that make sense
i first have to mention some known some
known polynomial time feasible classes
and the most famous one among these
would be the class of planar graphs so
there is a famous algorithm from the
1960s by Fisher castellane and temple a
which shows that counting perfect
matchings in planar graphs can actually
be reduced to the determinant and since
you know how to compute the determinant
we get a polynomial time I with him for
counting perfect matchings of planar
graphs and then this is a really nice
but it was actually generalized later so
it is also known that for every fixed
genus you you can get a polynomial time
algorithm and people didn't state it
that way but of course if you look at
the running time that this is an FPT
algorithm so if you're given a graph G
which is embedded on a surface of genus
k then you can count perfect matchings
in that graph in time for to the K times
n cube and essentially this works by
we're using this problem 24 to the K
linear combinations of determinants and
yeah so we get an FPT algorithm for the
genus and there's another parameter that
that could be interesting or actually we
can just generalize this this planar
algorithm in in another way so that
would be to a planar graph which has K
additional APCs so this just means that
we have a graph which is planar after
deleting this the set of blue vertices
which are called apex vertices and let's
assume that we are given these k apex
vertices together with our input then
you can actually get an algorithm that
runs some time n to the K plus 3 just by
applying boot force and the fkd method
because for each apex you just have to
guess its partner in the planar base
graph and then once you guessed all the
partners you can delete the apcs and
their partners and you end up with a
with an instance of counting perfect
matchings in the planar graph
and yeah so this parameter is nice
because it's fpt this one is probably
not so nice because well this is an
algorithm that solves it and we don't
know any I wouldn't say to it
significantly better so in the remainder
of this talk i will show among other
things that that this problem sharp w1
heart and this that this actually has
some nice implications reaching further
than than this specific hardness result
and to state those let me just survey
some graph parameters that are relevant
in this study of counting perfect
matchings so i mentioned before really
the genus and the apex number so the
epochs number of a graph just to recall
that is the minimum size of a vertex set
in in your graph such that deleting this
vertex set gives you a planar graph then
another parameter that is always nice to
studies of course the three with and all
of these parameters observe are subsumed
by more general parameters which is
called the hardware number so the
hardware number of a graph is just the
maximum number K such that your graph G
has a que clique minor so if this number
is bounded then you exclude some graph
as a minor and there are nice structural
properties of graphs excluding fixed
minors and maybe they could be used for
counting perfect matchings as well and
then there's a related number which is
very related to the harbinger number
which could be called the single
crossing hot bigger number of the singer
crossing liner number so this would just
be the minimum size of an excluded
single crossing minor so for instance
planar graphs exclude k 33 and k 5 so
they are seeing a crossing minor number
would be bounded by five because k 5 is
a graph that can be drawn in the plane
with at most one crossing as shown here
i should mention that the single
crossing graph is a graph that you can
draw on the plane with at most one
crossing and among these parameters you
you can define a hierarchy so if one
perimetry is bounded then then this can
also bound other parameters for instance
the trivial instance for for such a
relation would be well
the single crossing man your number is
bounded then of course you exclude some
graph so you also have about a tad
bigger number and also if you if you
have a graph of bondage eNOS then it's
known that such graphs exclude some pics
set of minors so you also have bonded
hard bigger number you can also show
that if the apex number is bounded you
also have pounded hard we got number and
in fact if you have boundary with and
you have single crossing number also
being bounded because graphs of boundary
with exclude a planar graph as a minor
and the planar graph is of course one
that can be drawn in the plane with it
most one crossing so these would be the
parameters that we that we looking at in
the following and let me just serve you
some algorithmic results that are known
for these parameters so for the genius
I've mentioned already before that
there's this for to the genus x + 2 n to
the Omega algorithm actually and so we
could recently show that that there is
no 2 to the little o of genus x poly an
algorithm for this problem under sharp
ETH phase so this exponential dependence
on the genus has to be there but we
don't quite know whether for is the
correct base in in the running time so
for the apex number and we have seen
this trivial brute force algorithm that
solves the problem time n to the K and
we can show that unless Sharpie th face
you cannot get it in time n to the
little of K over la que and also this
disheartens result also gives a sharp w1
hardness then considering three with
there is an algorithm that runs in time
to to the tree with x or working on the
tree decomposition and doing dynamic
programming with some extra trick so
this is a non trivial algorithm and we
could show that there is no 2 minus
epsilon to the tree with algorithm
unless the counting version of the
strongest potential time I potus's fails
but what is nice is that you can
actually generalize this tractability
result for tree with also to single
crossing mind
so it is known that if you exclude a
single crossing manner of size k then
you get a running time of F of K times
some polynomial and yeah this just
leaves open this last most general
parameter the advocate number so in this
setting just the lower bound for the
apex number will also give us a lower
bound for for accounting perfect
matchings under the hot bigger number
and but what we don't know is whether
this algorithm can be whether whether
this problem can be solved in time and
to some function of K so in fact we
don't even know whether really there is
some fixed graph class which excludes
some fixed minor and and the problem of
counting perfect matchings is already
Sharpie hard on that problem we don't
know whether such a graph class exists
could be that maybe if you like the hot
bigger number is just 100 or whatever
then you can actually go to set instance
into that problem we don't know they're
a surreal there ya ass at instance ok so
this is a survey of the results that I'm
aware of for for counting and perfect
matchings parameterize by structural
parameters of the graph and what I want
to show in the remainder of this talk is
how to prove such stuff so so we were so
in particular I want to show a lower
bound for the apex number under a
Sharpie th so I want to show that this
this trivial algorithm cannot be
improved by too much assuming the
Sharpie th holds and we have a general
proof approach for approving this kind
of these kind of statements so for
proving lower bounds and also for
proving for proving upper bounds we can
use the the so-called hold and framework
so I will explain later what that
actually is but but the general idea is
just that we start with some instance xk
to a parameterize problem we reduce this
to the evaluation of some quantity which
is called the homeland and then this
whole and problem will be with you
to counting perfect matchings on some
graph where the perimeter will be
bounded by some function of K and
there's a very nice and formal way of
doing these reductions so yeah to
explain how this works I first have to
introduce this notion of Holland
problems so a hole in problem is defined
as follows so the input to a holding
problem is a signature graph Omega the
signature graph is just some some graph
and at each vertex it has a so-called
signature attached to it so the the
signature red vertex V is just the
function f v which maps from binary
assignments to the edges incident with
v2 some complex number so let's have a
look at this example down here we have
this graph there is this green vertex
and the screen vertex might have this
particular signature so if the two edges
incident with that vertex are both
labeled zero it will output 40 and on
other assignments it will output
something different and generally you
can assign whatever signature you like
to a vertex and then once you have
defined a signature graph like this you
can define a quantity which is called
the whole length of that signature graph
so the homeland of a signature graph is
just the sum of all the edge assignments
to your to your graph and for each edge
assignment you look at this product here
so you take a product of all the
vertices appearing in your signature
graph and each vertex will look at the
assignment X restricted to the edges
incident with it it will evaluate the
signature on that given sub assignment
and then you take the product over all
these evaluations and you sum this up
for all edge assignments so this might
look a bit weird but let's have a first
example for for what you can encode as a
whole in problem so for instance we can
encode counting perfect matchings as a
holding problem in a very simple way
because you can just assign this perfect
matching signature to all vertices of
your graph so the perfect matching
signature just looks at
the edges incident with your vertex and
it outputs one if there is a unique one
among these edges otherwise it will
output zero and then you can see that if
you apply this perfect matching
signature to all vertices of your graph
then you end up with an instance for
counting perfect matchings in the graph
so to give an example for this this
would be an edge assignment and the blue
edges are those that are labeled one
then this this bottom vertex here this
vertex V will look at its incident edges
it will see that there is exactly one
edge which has labeled one so the
signature will output 1 and in fact
every vertex we do that because of
course every vertex has a unique edge
incoming and likewise so okay all these
vertices output 1 and if you take the
product of all these values you end up
with a 1 so a perfect matching will be
counted with a 1 and likewise if you
have some vertex at which this local
constraint is not fulfilled then that
vertex will give you a zero so that the
sign will not be counted in the hall and
so non perfect matchings will get value
zero and this is already nice because it
shows us that holy problems are more
general than then counting perfect
matchings and we can I mean it okay it
is this problem is in general more
general than counting perfect matchings
but we can encode county perfect
matchings in a natural way into it but
the fact that is more general allows us
to encode like arbitrary parameterize
problems into it as long as these have
some kind of local structure to it which
we can which we can capture by these
signatures all right so so it is often
easy to encode the parameterize problem
as a whole and problem but it turns out
that there is also a nice wave then
we're using holon problems back to
counting perfect matchings so this
special case of counting perfect
matchings is actually something that you
can often reduce a hole in problem two
and you can also do it in such a way
that or you can often do it in such a
way that's that like the parameter on
this instance that you get in the end
will be bound by some function of K and
to do to do this the second step in the
reduction
then you can use this notion of
so-called match gates which have been
studied before already so naturally it
is just a signature graph gamma on some
edge side II and some of these edges are
dangling so they have only one endpoint
instead of two and these match gates
have the property that every vertex has
has only the perfect matching signature
to it so all signature all signatures
appearing in a magic eight have the
perfect matching signature and then
essentially you can intuitively treats
imagicate like a single vertex which has
a given signature attached to it so you
can like in the formal way contract this
magic eight gamma to a single vertex
assign a signature to it which can be
computed from ghana and this signature
we look at edge assignments and 22 the
dangling edges of that gamma and output
some complex number and then the use
case for magic aids that that we will be
usually working with is that you have a
signature graph Omega and each vertex be
in that signature graph has some
signature FV and for each vertex you
also have a magic eight gamma V which
has exactly that signature then you can
insert this match gate at all vertices
to get some other signature graph Omega
Prime so I'll show in this animation
this was an insertion of a match gate at
V and then then you can check by a very
simple calculation that this operation
preserves the whole end so the
definition of these signatures and the
depression opponents allow you to to
just show this equality which is great
because now you end up with a with an
instance for Holand problem we're all
signatures are the perfect matching
signature so in other words you end up
with the problem of counting perfect
matchings as we've seen on that previous
slide all right so in other words we can
prove stuff via Holland problems by
taking some parameterize problem and
coding this as a whole in problem and
then using match gates to reduce this to
counting perfect matchings but I mean
it's great if
approach works and actually using this
approach we could prove the lower bound
for counting perfect matchings under the
genus perimeter on the tree with but but
often this relatively simple approach
doesn't work and we have to do some more
complicated stuff so actually what is
nice about the hole and framework is
that it can give you fpt with actors in
a very natural way so there is a very
intuitive way of reducing a hole and
problem Omega to some F of K instances
of other holland problems by some very
elementary linear algebra such that
these Honan problems might have
signatures that are better to deal with
or signatures that you can realize by
match gates in a better way so sometimes
this simple rule doesn't work and then
you have to reduce your problem too many
instances but this is okay in the
setting of an FPT reduction so how does
this second step work so in the second
step we're using something which is
called combined signatures or just
linear combinations of signatures and
let's say we have a signature graph
Omega and this signature graph has some
set of special vertices X and which
contains vertices V 1 up to BK at each
vertex which is not contained in X we
have the perfect matching signature and
at vertex V I in the set of special
vertices we have some special signature
fi and let's furthermore assume that for
each eye there are two match grade
signatures GI one and gy 2 such that you
can express fi as a linear combination
of these two magical signatures so here
this linear combination is to be
understood point wise so this holds that
every at every edge assignment and then
what you can show is that let's define
for each kate apple pie and over the set
over the set one and two for each step
skate up let's define a signature graph
Omega PI by replacing for each I in k
signature fi by the signature GI pi so
this original graph that we started with
had some special vertices which had
special signatures but each special
signature can be expressed as a linear
combination of two none special or
magical signatures and then we get these
graphs here where we placed all special
signatures by some particular choice of
these linear combination constituents
and you end up with graphs that have
only perfect matching signatures on it
or that have no special signatures left
and this can be used to to take a
signature graph which has some
signatures which are too complex for us
to realize we express these two we
express these special signatures which
are too complex as some linear
combination of simpler signatures and
then we end up with these graphs which
have only the simplest signatures in
them and the great thing is that by some
very elementary elementary algebra you
can show that the whole end of your
original signature growth of Omega is
just the Sun over all these holland's of
the derived signature graphs and in
general you can apply an arbitrary
linear combination at the step you don't
have to just take the Sun and you can
also take arbitrarily many constituents
into your combination and if you apply
this then you you end up with yeah so
the typical setting for doing this would
be that you you start with the
parameterize problem you transform this
to a whole and problem on some age of K
number of special vertices and yeah then
you use this simple Sun equation to get
some number of whole and problems which
have only non special vertices and then
you use match gates in the end to end up
with counting perfect matchings so in
particular we can use this approach for
reduction from counting so-called sparse
bread tilings to counting perfect
matchings on oh FK APCs and for this
problem we can show a lower bound which
is almost tight then we also get the
same lower bound for this problem
so so this works whenever you can
express a signature as a linear
combination whenever you can press all
your signatures as constant size linear
combinations of match get signatures
match grade signatures which has some
certain properties that you want to
enforce so for instance in our case you
want to have signatures which have
bounded apex number so you can just use
this photo but yeah the reduction the
previous slide would would just use a
magic eight signature in general and
generally you can apply pretty much any
signature as a simpler so it is
completely open to you what you want to
define as simpler simpler could mean
that it is just a magic eight signature
it could mean that is the signature of a
planar match gate it could mean that
this is a signature of a Magic eight
with two IPC's whatever this is just a
general way of breaking their own
complex signatures into less complex
signatures and the way I've presented it
on the previous slide was just that well
simply just mean it's a simple would
just mean it's a magic eight signature
okay let me just define first this this
problem of counting sparse grid tilings
so in the problem of counting sparse
grid-tie links we give pneus inputs two
numbers n and k and some special index
set s which is a subset of the pairs you
can build the with elements from 102 k
so you can imagine this problem to be
essentially grids which is a adjusted K
times K grid and then some of these
cells and that grids are special and for
each special cell you have this property
that you have a set a i j which is a
subset of the pairs you can get from 1
up to n and what you're interested in is
the number of pairs RC so ok what you're
interested in is the number of labelings
of the rows and the columns of that grid
such at at each special cell and the row
labeling and the column labeling taken
together as a pair is contained in that
set a IJ so ok this would be a possible
a possible labeling
of the columns this would be a possible
labeling of the rows then you wanted at
this special vertex a 32 and the pair 46
is contained in your set and this
problem can be shown to be sharp w1
complete and in fact it's it has a lower
bound of n to the Omega K over log K
time under sharp ETH even if the size of
the special set is linear NK yeah so
then we can reduce this problem which
obviously has a very local structure to
a signature graph Omega which is planar
and has linearly many special vertices
so yeah we take we just for each for
each cell we put a vertex and there will
be non special vertices and special
vertices we put some extra column column
vertices into our graph and some extra
roll vertices and edges so each edge
bander is a set of n parallel edges that
runs vertically we do the same
horizontally and then we assign the
perfect matching signatures to the role
vertices to the column vertices and the
role vertices and certain cells
signatures to the other vertices so
there will be a cell signature which is
non special and the special service
signature and these signatures together
we'll just ensure that the homeland of
the signature graph and encodes the
number of those pairs and I mean you
just have to believe me that this can be
expressed as the organ problem but it
should be believable because this
problem has very local nature to it like
at each vertex you can check whether
when it is this condition is fulfilled
and then essentially what we're doing is
so we take this seller signature we
realize it by a planar magic eight and
we take the special cell signature and
realize it by a linear combination of a
planar magic eight and a to apex
Medicaid so altogether this gives us a
reduction from counting sparse great
tilings which has this lower bound to
counting whole ends in a planar
signature graph
Oh FK special vertices and then using
this linear combination of match gates
we insert planar match gates and to Apex
match gates and so we insert planar
match case at the non special vertices
and we insert planar match gates and
possibly also to apex and educates at
the special vertices so the worst we can
get this is an instance which has 0 of K
a pc set it so this would be an example
where we use linear combinations not
just to express as a magic eight but
actually to express as a magic eight
which has an additional bounded
parameter so the apex number would be
bonded so what exactly is a failure
match game I that match gate is just a
perfect matching so a planar match kid
would just be a match guedes as we've
defined before and additionally you have
some you can draw it in the plane such
that all these dangling edges are on the
outer face a green project you have is a
bit essentially yeah you can essentially
just consider this vertex as some it
hides some gadget underneath and this
gadget is actually the planar drawing of
some of some other gadget graph yeah and
if you insert such to apex educates into
a planar brafton then you can see that
like the epochs number will just be two
times the number of insertion Signet ok
so then we get this lower bound as well
all right then let me just conclude my
talk so this talk consists of two parts
in the first part we are considering the
sub graph counting problem where you
were given a pattern and the host your
prime interest by the size of the
pattern and you wanted to count the
number of H copies in that graph you've
seen that this problem is sharp w1 hard
if you have a if you are considering
matchings and we also considered
counting perfect matchings and their
structural parameters I mentioned that
this program is fpt by genus tree with
and excluded one crossing minors and
I've given a sketch of how to show that
the problem is chef w1 heart under the
epics number and yeah let me just
mention some open problems so one big
open problem would be if you can count
perfect match
and parameterize by the hard worker
number in time n to the F of K so what
do we know here so we know that we can
handle it surfaces of bounded genus in
FP t time we can handle a pcs in time n
to the K and we can do significantly
better we can handle click sounds of
surfaces that have a pcs attached to
them and but what we cannot do is
handing vortices so in fact we already
run into a problem or we are already
devastated by the very simple case of
having a plane with one vortex on it and
if someone could solve that that would
be pretty great if you can come perfect
matchings in a graph that has the
display gnar up to one vertex and then
another thing would be if you can
improve this lower bounds which is known
for this problem of deciding whether
graph has a colorful sub graph on L
edges so there you have this lower bound
of n to the Omega L over L can you get
an improvement if you considering
counting instead of deciding and also
can you get a faster with accounting
perfect matchings parameterize by APCs
so he actually you have even a further
restriction that you may impose on the
problem it's even okay to count just
modulo 2 to the K the number of perfect
matchings and if you had a faster way to
accounting perfect matchings and K apex
graphs modulo 2 to the K you would also
end up with an with a fast urban for
this problem and just because this seems
to be one of the weirder connections
between this problem and some other
problem i would suggest looking at it
okay and so this concludes my talk and
for everyone who watched this on youtube
don't forget to subscribe the Simon's
Institute to get more results on
complexity ETH HRW one
and thank you for your attention
when you hear that that dichotomy by
kowalick on based on the size of maximum
matching in in the pattern graph H and
if that's bounded then counting what's
the exponent of the polynomial visit
dependent that bound is the bow shock
than the xbox so there isn't a burden
that allows you to count century in time
n to the vertex cover I think that could
possibly be a please hit that down out
of the exponent is that right
Thank gravity the entire graph is a
vertex cover of incense and there is w 1
half w sharp hardness of the number w 1
how does the second side so like so I
mean you cannot be kept fpt paralyzed by
the size of the graph you're looking for
I thought I mean according to this
so he's counting perfect matching safety
if I'm attacked by click good no we
actually have a sharp w2 hardness reside
try to mention because it's a bit weird
because then so all these algorithms
that I mentioned before and they they
also work in weighted cases and well
click within weighted graphs is usually
something that doesn't make too much
sense but if you if you just
parameterize by click with you end up
with a sharp w to work in school and
actually a tight lower bound under ACTH
so you can solve it in time n to the K
plus some constant but if you could
solve it in n to the K minus another
constant then you would have broken ACTH
and this holds for every fixed click
with k
thanks